good afternoon welcome to the
the 2014 day of data
our panelists this afternoon are
professor Mark Gerstein he is the Albert
Williams professor of biomedical
informatics at Yale he's co-director of
the Yale computational biology and
bioinformatics program his research is
focused on bioinformatics and he's
interested in large-scale integrative
surveys biological database designed
macro mouths Krieger geometry molecular
simulation human genome annotation gene
expression analysis and data mining
event that is a sentence the next
speaker will would be Professor pinch le
Hall she's an assistant professor in the
department of geology and geophysics at
Yale and her her research focuses on
understanding open ocean ecosystems
through the Cenozoic disentangling the
causes and consequences of mass
extinctions and quantifying community
response to global change in the third
speaker speaker will be angel angel sue
she graduated from the Yale School of
Forestry and environmental studies in
2013 and she is now an associate
research scientist and lecturer at FPS
as well as the director of the
environmental performance measurement
program area her research focuses on
Chinese environmental performance
measurement government's governance and
policy professor Christine so first of
all I want to thank the organizers for
inviting me to the day of data which
I've enjoyed immensely so so far and I
just want to say I really appreciate the
introduction but one word was missing
out of the introduction it's my new word
I now think of myself as a data
scientist it's fine
focused on data science and that is that
encompasses now my my research so that's
what I'm gonna be talking talking to you
about today biological data science and
in particular how we can use that to
make a map of the human genome and use
that as a tool against cancer so first
of all I want to put big data in biology
in the context of big data in general in
science I mean you've probably all heard
today that big data is transforming
science many different types of Sciences
it's obviously transforming Biological
Sciences and the big thing in biological
science which is a little different than
in other disciplines it's really been
transformed by a particular one
particular technology
not isreally diagrammed in this slide
here that is the amazing event of next
generation sequencing the ability to
generate just gargantuan amounts of data
quickly and so this graph shows the
decrease in cost of genome sequencing
since the human genome project finished
around 2000 and it's on a log graph so
of course you can see it's kind of
exponentially going down in price and is
paralleling Moore's law for the increase
in speed and memory of computers but
around 2007 due to some tremendous
advances some of them here in New Haven
by 454 Biosystems next generation
sequencing really took off and you can
see this the is that's incredible you
know decrease in cost which is now
leveling off but that really has led to
this tremendous amount of new data and
that's really changed the dynamics of
the the economic dynamics of genomics
where it used to be initially that most
of the money and genomics went in to
sequencing because that was the center
of gem sequencing now more and more what
you're really seeing is money devoted to
analysis of genome sequencing and also
procuring interesting samples it's not
just a generic human genome it's a very
particular genome or say a disease
patient and so forth so the this large
amount of sequencing has given rise to
these huge databases that have terabytes
and petabytes of information in them and
I thought I'd give you a sense of the
sort of database world in genomics at
the moment this picture is from heidi
sofia at the NHGRI and she's made this
kind of a astronomical view of our
databases now but I think it's
interesting to see this is a little bit
old so I think these numbers have one up
cancer lis since them but basically the
public databases you can see they're
sort of terabytes Gale databases the
biggest one is about a petabyte scale
that people download and what is in
those petabytes the biggest one is that
cancer genomics database called TCGA and
if you look at that you can see it this
is a little text a little hard to see
here but basically it's split into many
different cancers say this line
represents breast cancer which is one of
the most intensively studied counselors
and then if you split that up you can
see that it
in two different experiments that people
have done such as genome sequencing RNA
sequencing and so forth and these
experiments have different profiles in
terms of the amount of data they
generate and so forth and I'm going to
be coming back later to this cancer
genomics data what do people do with big
data so what is the goal of amassing
these massive datasets well
fundamentally I think the goal is to
answer questions and really also to make
models and use those models to make
predictions about the real world and in
in kind of doing that I kind of divide
the approach up into two ways one is
where people just want the answers to
the question and they don't care so much
about the explicit structure of the data
they don't care about how the data is
set up they just want to answer that
question and I think of this as kind of
like Google search you know you don't
really know how the Internet's all
structure you put in your query into the
box and you get your answer that's what
you care about another one is where
people intensely care about the explicit
description of the data and what does it
look like and of course I think the
paradigm here is also Google but it's
Google Maps as opposed to Google search
where you really want to understand this
is what the earth looks like and that
structure means something sheer so how
do we think of genomics and scientific
computing in these cont in these in
terms of this dichotomy well let me
start off with contrast so last year we
heard about this amazing discovery of
the Higgs boson and I think maybe some
physicists here will disagree but I
think this represents a kind of example
the first type of thing where they had
just petabytes gargantuan amounts of
data but at the end they were searching
for this tremendous needle in this
haystack you know to find a few events
that really support this this particle
this god particle and and you know so
then they were happy with those those
events in that context and the contrast
we heard about earlier today is really I
think the astronomers view and so we
heard earlier about this Sloan Digital
Sky Survey earlier today but I think
this is an inspiration to a lot of
people in large-scale data science I
mean this is kind of you know the
universe seeing it all in one hole and
that's a tremendous inspiration it has
been for me and so what I think we want
to do in genomics is actually very
similar to that Sloan Digital Sky Survey
and drawing inspiration fat the only
problem of course is that we don't have
as an intuitive model as a celestial
sphere or the earth so we have to make a
model to make a map of and so the encode
project that I'm going to talk about has
been trying to make a map of the human
genome and what we want to do with this
map is layer on all this different type
of data but the problem of course is the
map is a little bit less intuitive so
I'm going to be talking about that map
today and I should also want to say a
little bit about the encode project
which I think this relates to how big
data is done big data is generated by
big crowds crowds of people and crowds
are also known as consortium and they're
organized to some degree and so the
human genome is analyzed is annotated
about this big consortium called encode
and that really kind of was created
after the sequencing of the human genome
around the 2001-2002 and it went through
a number of very organized pilots first
looking at one percenter genome then
looking at model organisms eventually -
whole roll outs on the entire human
genome giving some sense of the
annotation so what is the annotation of
the genome look like or how do people
think about it well I think a big thing
in the encode group is to try to present
all this information in an organized way
and so we I think a good model for the
organization is a hierarchy okay the
idea is you don't want to go straight to
all the data you want to kind of
approach it in a structured way and so
you can imagine at the bottom there's
the data and the data actually if you
start with the images it would be
gargantuan amounts but if you just start
with the region you're talking obviously
many terabytes of reads those reads of
course turn into so signals or sort of
noisy signals on the genome and then
they're processed into progressively
more simplified representations that
I'll show you Sur Peaks networks models
and eventually people write papers on
them but even in writing the papers
people want to do this in the kind of
organized fashion so the public
presentation of the papers is there's
many papers they're arranged around a
central paper that's kind of meant to be
looked at first and then there's maybe
20 or 30 papers around around that that
are kind of referenced that central
paper nor referenced by it and they in
turn describe the methods for particular
data set so the thought processes you
can Traver
this huge data trove in an organized
fashion and that's really the goal of
that construction so what I've this is
the outline for I was going to talk to
you about today and I might not have
time to go through all bits of it but I
at the beginning I wanted to just tell
you about big data in genomics this map
making now I wanted to do a little bit
of a dive and kind of show you what
we're doing what does the data look like
what are we really trying to do to show
you a view of our sort of linear
annotation how we annotate the genome
and maybe this higher level network
annotation and then I want to give you a
sense of how we can apply this in a
practical way you know in medical
context for say prioritizing cancer of
mutations so first of all the linear
annotation so how do we think about the
linear annotation of the genome well I
think if it very much like the way
people would annotate books in libraries
and you know how that that's where the
word comes from right so here's a bit of
text that I've taken specially from
American scientists and I've tried to
annotate it and for me annotating often
is get a highlighter out of a different
color and you highlight it and then you
put a little marginal note that says
what is that the significance of that
piece of text that you've highlighted
you've functionally highlighted that
piece of text another thing that people
do when they annotate text is they take
a number of text and they compare them
they say this text is like another text
or they say within this text there's a
particular phrase or light motif that's
repeated over and over again and that
forms a type of on annotation so let's
take those ideas and now think about the
genome and we can sort of think about
the same way so first of all let's talk
about that comparison of text that comes
about in terms of thinking about
conservation in the genome we can take
the human genome compare it to itself
compare it to other people in the
population or can compare it amongst the
human and other model organisms looking
for conservation at different levels
then let's think about the highlighter
we can highlight the genome the way we
do this is by doing a functional
genomics experiment that gives a very
noisy readout of what the genome is
doing is it being read out is it being
bound - is it being wrapped up what's
happening and then of course the
computer people process this signal and
turn it into these little highlighter
blocks that's the kind of mindset very
similar to what we do with text so now
I'm gonna take a little bit of a dive
and show you what this actually looks
like for finding regulatory sites in the
genome so here's a signal
this is very noisy signal this signal
has a variety of things we use to
process it we have to compare it versus
and control we have to deal with the
math ability and so forth and we find
little regions that we call regulatory
sites these are bound to by
transcription factors and are kind of
the wiring of our our genome now one key
aspect of all this wiring in the genome
is most of the wiring sits outside of
genes okay and so people refer to this
as being in the dark matter of the
genome this of course is a very
astronomical analogy also and I thought
it kind of fun and I hope there's some
astronomers here to correct me to kind
of compare this to real dark matter so
supposedly this is a picture of dark
matter and supposedly the way I
understand is you cannot see dark matter
but what you see is you see its effect
on the light of from coming from stars
and the way it lenses the light of stars
and this is very similar it's the way we
want to think about the regulatory bits
of the genome you look at their effect
on the genes the genes are like the
stars they are regulated and lens by the
regulatory regions in the genome so
that's what we're looking at now the
next thing we're going to do is look at
the kind of conservation of the
regulatory sites that second type of
annotation so in general people this is
a bit of a technical graph and I'm not
going to describe in detail what
basically people have found that they
have they're very weakly conserved and
mostly the genes are very strongly
conserved but if we break all the
regulatory sites up into more specific
sites we start to see some of them are
conserved to a degree and if we actually
look in detail at the mutations that hit
them we can see they particularly
disrupt the binding sites of things in
certain ways and so the long short of
this is that we can find groups of
regulatory sites that are both
functional as being bound to but they're
also conserved so we start with a list
of 677 categories we develop smaller
lists of groups of sites that are
conserved and they're actually as
conserved as genes and we see lots and
because of that we see lots of the known
deleterious mutations are in them okay
and so this allows us to find regions of
the genome that are very sensitive to
mutations we're going to come back to
this so that's sort of the linear
annotation
so now let's move from the linear
annotation to a higher-level ization so
when you're annotation is very nice but
it's a very unstructured type of
annotation it's very much like the parts
list and you know if you're a true
molecular biologist with a capital M you
want to look at molecules also with a
capital M you want to look at how
molecules work how they move what
happens in three dimensional and four
dimensional space and time that is
unfortunately too ambitious for the
current world we are on the genome we
can't do that for every molecule in the
genome so what happens is this network
representation which is kind of like a
2d sketch in between the 1d parts list
and the 3d molecular picture is a kind
of nice way of thinking about things
functionally so this network website is
very powerful and we find in molecular
biology that we can input a lot of ideas
that we have about molecules such as
their transcriptional regulation their
physical protein protein interactions in
this same representation and one thing
that's also very powerful about networks
is there's a whole new world that's I'd
say part of data science now springing
up called network science we're people
studying networks so we have a new
Institute here at Yale the Yale Network
Institute and the neat thing is you can
also draw these network pictures for
lots of other disciplines so in
particular one of the favorite ones is
to draw pictures of social networks and
the nice thing about these other
disciplines does people have much better
intuition for them than they do about
the kind of bizarre molecules or the
genomes kind of tables and chairs for
this world that makes sense so here's a
social network that I've drawn I've
taken from the New York Times it's
called the blame game and it shows the
dirt the arrows represent blame and a
particular event that happened to notice
how one person even blaming himself and
the key thing about this picture though
that's amazing this is our social and
twisters if you just look at the arrows
you immediately get a sense of who's in
charge who's the master regulator right
and so what we want to do is you want to
take those intuitions of how we can look
at those those arrows and replace that
the talking heads here by genes and then
we can understand the gene regulatory
network so practically what do we do to
make up a gene regulatory network I'm
not going to go into the details a
little bit of a dive here what we do is
we find these sites in the genome okay
then the simple thing we do is for the
science that are right upstream of genes
we basically say they control the genes
and if we do that we end up with a
network that connects a transcription
factor to a target gene through a
binding site that has about a half a
million edges in it it's a big hairball
and for a lot of people who don't like
networks it represents a very messy
hairball and so to simplify it we've
developed ways of cutting the terrible
all down to about 25,000 edges okay that
we can analyze now the distal sites that
are far away from genes we have to do
other things further and I'm not going
to talk about them so now if we take
this hairball that connects the two
25-thousand edges and we also relate it
to all of the other networks that
contain genes we have we get this sort
of human network that's a hundred
thousand edges now you look at this this
is a criticism people have of a lot of
big data science they look at that and
they say that doesn't mean anything to
me it just looks like a huge hairball
and that is true however one of the neat
things about mining that data is if you
look at it in detail you can actually
find some really interesting things you
can find that the genes that are more
essential in the human genome they tend
to sit more at hubs and because of the
way this network is drawn you can almost
see it as more in the center of this
network whereas the less important genes
sit more at the periphery and so we're
going to come back to this idea of the
hubs being more essential okay so now
we've talked about big data in genomics
the making the maps just how we develop
a kind of simple annotation a linear
annotation developing a more elaborate
synthetic second level of network
annotation and so now I want to talk
about what what do we do with this how
can we use it and how do we think about
how it works with big data ok so the
problem we're going to approach is how
do we prioritize mutations in cancer
this is a big problem let me explain the
problem if you contract cancer and
unfortunately many people in this room
probably well what will happen when they
sequence your tumor genome well they'll
find thousands of mutations cancer is a
disease of the genome so on order
they'll find maybe 5,000 mutations
and now 5,000 is a small number it's
much less than the normal number of
variants in a person but it's a lot you
know what are we gonna do with 5,000 how
are we going to target drugs that how we
can do experiments this so what we want
to do is we want to reduce that 5,000
down to a few key mutations that are
gonna give rise to the drugs that
doctors can prescribe and the things
that people are going to focus research
on so it's called prioritizing those
5,000 mutations so we're gonna talk
about how we can use our map now to
search those mutations and prior to them
so we're going to start with all that
big data from cancer and we're gonna
look in particular at the cancer genome
sequencing here I just show a selection
of whole genome sequences of prostate
and breast cancer it's about a hundred
in total now most of these mutations in
these in these cancers 99% of them occur
outside of genes and so there's been
there's always a my optic focus in
genetics on genes because that's what we
understand most but when you look in an
unbiased way at the mutations that occur
in a disease most of them occur outside
of genes so 99% of these mutations occur
outside the genes and so we want to
understand which of those mutations are
driving the cancer which are important
so we're just going to do is we put
together a very simple scheme that we're
gonna use to prioritize based on
annotation so we're gonna take our
mutations and basically we're gonna say
do they go into any of the art do they
head into those sensitive regions in the
genome that are both functional and
conserved okay then we're gonna give
them say a point and then we're gonna
ask are they particularly disruptive do
they mess up this a the binding site and
then we're gonna ask do they hit one of
those network hubs you know if they hit
a hub maybe they're more deleterious
okay so we're looking for mutations that
are very different from the normal
pattern of variation and then we up
weighed it and prioritize that so what
happens when we actually do that on a
real cancer genome so this is a one
prostate cancer genome sequenced in
about probably 2000 or at least
described initially in 2011 and it
contained about 2,000 mutations it to
many to look at but we can ask you know
how many are in a sensitive region how
many rahab and so forth and the key
thing is at the end we get down to one
one mutation and this Worr mutation
people can do follow-up experiments on
they can drill into detail what's going
on
this mutation and it turns out you can
actually see to some degree it drives
the cancer so then next thing we did is
we tried to go from an idea into a
practical piece of code that people can
use which is of course much more
difficult than actually having an idea
so we tried to develop an actual web
server that people could upload variants
to and they could use to prioritize
their mutations that we call this web
server or fun seek and let me tell you a
little bit about the structure of the
web server because I think it gives you
a little bit of a sense of how you think
about the data so we have this huge data
context okay that I want to talk about
and then we have our variants which are
much smaller variant ly a few thousand
variants you can upload them to a web
server you can email them around others
privacy concerns sometimes but just in
general they're not very large data we
have this huge data context and so we
imagine we put them together and then we
get a prioritization that's the kind of
high level of what happens then we think
about this data context what we do in
the data context is we put a lot of
effort to taking all these very big data
sets such as the thousand genomes
probably morphisms the encode
annotations and building kind of a
simplified data context that is big but
is maybe not the terabyte scale it's
maybe only a few tens of gigabytes ok
it's something that people can download
it's something that you can manipulate
so there's I think the big issue in
dealing with large data is kind of
processing into smaller more manageable
things there's very much like the way
when you take a picture in your camera
now you can't actually deal with the raw
image you deal with the processed lossy
JPEG that's what you actually deal with
and likewise we want to deal with kind
of simplifications of this large data
sets and then of course the within the
variant prioritization we have all these
different features and we have this idea
of a recurrence I'm not going to go into
these in any detail just to say that we
use the the hubs and we use the
sensitive regions and other these sort
of site breaking things and so forth and
we weight them in various sort of
entropy based weighting scheme that we
use for the data I'm just gonna zip
through this I think I'm a little going
a little bit over so let me just
summarize what I've told you about today
so what I've told you about is a case
study in biological data science and
basically how we make a map of the
genome and how we use it as a tool and
first I wanted to introduce you this
mapmaking idea for how to think about
big data which is really contrasting to
the kind of search idea then I wanted to
talk to you about practically well how
do we make the map you know one is the
very simplified you know the continental
outlines and so forth and then another
is a more synthetic view which is a
network II type of thing and for the
sort of linear annotation we talked
about finding regulatory sites conserve
regulatory sites and for the network
thing we talked about how we build that
network and then also how we find that
the hubs in the network are more
constrained and then how we take these
two facts two very simple facts and use
them to build a conceptual workflow to
prioritize mutations in cancer and then
how we build a software tool based on
that and how in building the software
tool we have to again think about
separating the very large data context
from kind of this sort of medium data
context smaller files that you can move
around on the web and you can process
with and you know of course I know that
most of this is targeted to a biological
audience but I think genomics has been a
big data discipline for a while and I
think a big part of data science is
learning from other other big data
disciplines and so I I draw inspiration
from Pandora which described its its
website is the Music Genome Project so
they've obviously learned from genomics
and you know we I think through a lot of
discussions such as that that today's
forum we can have a lot of
back-and-forth with different
disciplines to learn things and so
finally I want to acknowledge a lot of
people involved and as I described to
you before this is a crowd this is crowd
science okay a lot of people involved in
this and so it's hard to acknowledge
people properly and give them credit
right if there's so many people so I'm
gonna try to do that really quick now so
the encode consortium you know maybe 500
to a thousand people it's broken into a
group and the group that I talked about
their work is called the networks
elements group it's about 50 people
these are the people here and the group
it's nice it's really split between the
people who generate these very large
data sets such as Rick Myers and Mike
Myers it has been often Mike Snyder at
Stanford and the analysts and some of
those people here for instance I'd like
to acknowledge or is offski who's
associate research scientist with me
Chow Chang who you
to be a post alchemy now has a faculty
position at Dartmouth cuckoo yawn who's
another associate research scientist
with me who really led a lot of this
analysis the can surprise even more
complicated this is a collision of
consortium so no it is fascinating
socially so we have the thousand genomes
consortium which this is formally part
of which is also known as a thousand
authors consortium we have more authors
and you have genomes there's a subgroup
of this 50 people that's called the
functional interpretation group that's
what this group did these are all the
green people here and they include
myself and also actor Khurana who is a
associate research scientist I mean now
she's moved on to a faculty position at
Cornell and this group collided with
another consortium really the TCGA or
the cancer group and this particular
small group here you see kind of merge
with them okay and this was led by Mark
Rubin at Weill Cornell in New York who
helped with the a lot of the cancer
genomics and also key in this endeavor
was ano foo who was a cbv graduate
student here in the yeah who really
developed a lot of the software that I
described for this cancer prioritization
and with that I'll thank you for your
attention
okay all right well I'm gonna follow up
with the talk that I hopefully ties in
quite well off of the previous speaker
because I'm gonna be talking about
measuring the shape of life rather than
measuring the genomes that underpin it
and because of the broad audience here
today the goal of my talk really is to
give you an idea of the different
opportunities challenges and data that
are involved in measuring the shape of
life and talk about what I've done to
with my broader group to leverage the
resources that are available here at
Yale and one of my big hopes is that in
talking to you all we can talk about
ways that the data infrastructure and
scientific computing that have been
developed in other fields can be used in
the shape of life as well so before I
get to the opportunities and challenges
of the science I want to start with a
story to emphasize the point that shape
matters so the summer I was lucky enough
to be in Africa following a researcher
guy Western he studies lions
out into the field one morning and we
happened across these two darling little
wildebeests wandering across the savanna
and a few seconds later the five or six
lions that were creeping along the edges
attacked the wildebeest and killed it
now you can imagine that had that
wildebeest had slightly longer legs or
had he jumped a little bit harder or
perhaps you know had he been a little
bit more attentive because he really did
not seem to be paying much attention he
might have gotten out of the way of
those Lions and so all of those aspects
I just described are things that can be
called a phenotype so the different
characteristics the expressed
characteristics that define an organism
and shape is a phenotype certain people
have longer legs can run a bit faster
than I can for instance certain people
who are better at climbing there's a lot
of different aspects in our morphology
that affects how we interact with the
environment so shape matters in a
doesn't just matter when it comes to
things like predation it also matters in
in interactions that can be mutually
beneficial to both parties involved like
here you see this darling little bird
also in Africa about two feet on a
flower and the flower shaped in such a
way that when the bird feeds it it also
gets pollen on its forehead and carries
pollen off to pollinate other flowers
and even though we can imagine shape
mattering more in things like lions and
wildebeests and birds and flowers it
also matters to organisms that are a
little bit stranger to us so these are
our strange organisms on land but in my
research I study the strange organisms
in the sea and imagining the causes and
the importance of phenotype in the sea
or shape is a little bit more difficult
because they live in a three-dimensional
environment they can be seen from all
directions they're floating it's a vast
realm so understanding exactly what
their phenotype does is a little bit of
a bigger problem but the most important
thing to take away is that even though
shape matters for how organisms interact
with their environment we typically
measure genotypes
much better than we measure shape and
this isn't to say that we shouldn't be
measuring genotypes because
understanding the genomes or the genes
that underlie these different expressed
characters is critically important for
understanding evolution in both the past
and short-term variations in populations
today but if we're gonna understand the
link between genotype and phenotype we
have to measure the phenotype or shape
as well and this came in very personal
to me because I actually studied both
genotypes and phenotypes in these fish
here and the amazing thing was with
next-generation sequencing we were able
to sequence the genomes of across these
fish with in the order of like a week a
few weeks but when I went to measure the
phenotype to measure its shape I sat
there for two months painstakingly
putting little dots all over this fish
and in its in its jaws to actually
describe what the phenotype was doing so
we are measuring the genotype much
better than we measure the phenotype and
we need to get on par with when it comes
to measuring shape because in the end
phenotype or shape is the variation that
natural selection acts on and here
this is my favorite group of organisms I
hope you guys it's not showing up so
well
these are planktonic foraminifera these
are single-celled organisms that have
that form a fossa that form a shell as
they grow and they're found throughout
the world's oceans so even though you've
probably never seen them before there's
millions and billions of them in the
ocean and when it comes to measuring
phenotypes it's recognized that
phenomics is really the next grand
challenge people are measuring different
expressions of the of organisms not just
their shape but also their metabolisms
or other aspects of their behavior but
we're not measuring it on the same same
scale so really the goal of the talk
today is to talk through what the
opportunity is when it comes to
measuring shape what the data is that we
need to be collecting and what the
challenges are and really we've been
working quite hard at this in my group
for the last year so I'm gonna give our
work as a case study so what's the
opportunity when it comes to measuring
shape well the amazing thing is we
actually have the material the tools and
the methods to be measuring phenotypes
to be measuring shape at the same scale
that we're measuring genotypes to start
with organisms are everywhere that's
what makes walking around so interesting
and when it comes to thinking about the
fossil record which is where my research
lies there are actually huge numbers of
fossils ever since Darwin complained
about the notorious gaps in the fossil
record I think a lot of people wrote it
off but if you go out into the open
ocean today and you look at the bottom
of the ocean in many parts of the ocean
there are literally football fields deep
sediments that are made entirely of
fossils those fossils are entirely
microscopic so you're talking about
billions to trillions of fossils sitting
there waiting to tell you about things
like variation and evolution in the
fossil record so we just need to measure
them and the amazing thing is we use
these very same fossils in my case my
darling Foreman if for a to do things
like reconstruct the evolution of past
climates so we heard a little bit about
the difficulties and the importance of
understanding climate dynamics in the
past earlier today
but the amazing thing is the climate
system interacts with biology because
biology is the carbon store for the
climate system you know and many times
and it's one of the big uncertainties
when it comes to understanding climate
dynamics today and in the past what is
the response of biota and how does that
interact with the climate system but
even though we can draw this here is
actually a curve of oxygen isotopes
which can be interpreted in terms of
temperature let's go from back when the
dinosaurs ruled the day up to the
present day so you can see the long term
changes in the climate system and the
reason why the the dots are all
scattered is because we have so much
data you actually can't see at this
scale the fine-scale
resolution so we have this for
temperature we have this for carbon but
we don't have this when it comes to the
biota themselves so we can't tell you
even though the fossils are there we
can't tell you how rapidly these
different species are evolving to these
changes so the opportunity is really
there we just need to measure it and
when it comes to what can we measure in
the fossil record at least in the open
ocean you actually have representatives
of many different parts of the whole
ecosystem so you're not just looking at
one group of organisms you can look at
many groups of organisms at once but to
do this you're gonna have to use more
tools than we traditionally use so in
the past when it comes to looking at
variation in the fossil record we do it
the way I described with the fish you
take out 1020 falls out of a jar oh I
forgot to tell you these jars of fossils
so each one of these data points comes
from a jar like this and a single jar
can have something like 2 to 10 million
fossils in it that's a lot of fossils
but instead of actually measuring them
we tend to just take out 10 - maybe a
few hundred and give them a name and
maybe measure one or two aspects of its
shape but instead what we're doing in my
group here is trying to use multiple
different methods to measure shape and
tie across them with informatics so I've
talked a little bit about the
traditional way of just of quantifying
shape by putting little points on an
object but you can also quantify shape
by taking really resolved
three-dimensional measures and that's
through micro or nano CT scanning
approach and that's actually been used
to great effect for a lot of recent
research on the evolution of morphology
but it's difficult to quantify variation
because this is so expensive and so slow
that you can get a very good
understanding of a few individuals but
you can't study the millions or the
thousands of individuals that will tell
you about the variation within a
population the variation that underlies
evolution itself so what we're doing in
my lab is focusing on rapid
high-throughput approaches um semi 3d
morphometrics and other other faster
methods like grain size and shape
analysis through high-throughput flow
systems in order to increase the amount
of information that we have in with the
genomic analogy when you measure things
by next-generation sequencing there is a
bit of a trade-off between the precision
of the measurement and the speed at
which you get it and I'm proposing the
same trade-off when it comes to
morphology we will get something out of
having more information even if there's
more noise in that information and the
final piece of why we should just be
doing this already is that we actually
have methods that have already been
published and already have been tested
for dealing with this high-throughput
morphological data so this here is just
an example from doug boyars group where
they've basically been using automated
3d morphological comparisons to compare
teeth so the teeth that they measure
they just have a relatively small set of
teeth but they've measured them with
micro CT scanning and so our group is
taking these same methods and then
applying them to the tens of thousands
of fossils that were measuring with semi
semi 3d method methods so although the
opportunities there the fossils or the
living organisms exist
the methods exist in the tools with
which to measure these shapes exist we
aren't really doing it at the scale that
we need to be doing as a broader
community so the a lot of the work in my
lab is built around the premise that
closing this gated data gap is doable
and well worth doing and for many
questions it depends on your question of
course but for many questions you just
want to skip straight to the trait data
and look at things like variation
shake so I'm going to talk about one
type of data today and the key type of
data is measuring the shape of my
microphone 2d and semi 3d measurements
so basically each of these fossils this
is the planktonic 4minute for a
single-celled organism each one of them
is on the scale of one tenth to one
millimeter in size so these are about
the size of a grain a small salt or
quite a bit smaller in fact but you can
see from this picture that their
morphology varies quite a bit and so
there's actually a morphological
taxonomy that matches up with with
genetics so we can actually identify two
species with each one of these are
organisms are and when you look at these
organisms you can see within a
population that their shape varies quite
a bit so what we're doing is we're going
to sites around the global ocean today
throughout the Atlantic primarily and
for the last 80 million years to create
a database of morphological variation
within these fossils and to start we're
starting in the Atlantic today and we've
been trying to minimize the noise in our
data by orienting the fossils and
prepping them in a certain way and here
you can see one of our slides and the
students that are prepping the slides
have been getting so bored that they've
been making patterns like Yale and we
had things like running horses and waves
but the goal of this calibration data
set is to basically deal with the fact
that if you just toss fossils on a
microscope slide they have a random
orientation whereas if you organize them
from a common orientation it minimizes
the noise so we're testing to see if we
can skip that orientation step in the
future because it it really is quite
painstaking but over the last year we've
managed to put together about 20 sites
at this point which means that we have
on the order of 50,000 individuals that
have been measured but going but
starting essentially a new approach to
measuring phenotypes was a really
daunting endeavor and getting off the
ground was helped dramatically by the
data infrastructure here at yeah
so what did we do so we bought a
microscope that is better used
oftentimes in histology but we rerigged
it so you can use reflected light so
it's an automatic little robot
microscope that steps around and takes a
three-dimensional slices through an
object we bought a data storage server
with 50 terabytes so we could put our
data somewhere and we looked in the
different options for say for storing
and sharing this data and really when it
came to solving all of these problems at
every single step it was a big there
were multiple hurdles because nobody's
done that done this in this way for for
fossils before so he worked with people
in the different microscope companies to
come up with the best system for our
needs within Yale we worked with a lot
of people on the storage and computing
side I have to say when I first started
this I was worried about properly
identifying each one of these fossils
because as soon as you go through a
slide I have to go back to this as soon
as you go through the slide like this it
has you know each one of those
individuals needs its own ID and its own
information with where it comes from and
so I sent an email out to Yale's Network
and Kristin sort of caught me and said
hey we have the infrastructure to help
you deal with this let's get a team
together and figure out the best way to
put information on your images to store
them and to make them accessible to the
public so if you're starting out in a
new field I think one of the big
takeaway message here at Yale is that
there are people here that are actually
willing and excited to help you to come
up with the best solution so that was a
really amazing thing that I've been to
have the chance to work with everyone
over the last year and so what we've
done up until this point is basically
build the informatics pipelines to go
from having a slide to having the data
out the other end so if you look at a
slide like this the first thing that we
do is we automatically identify all the
objects we cut them up into unique
objects and we smack a label on them and
that label I don't know if you guys can
read it very well but it basically says
it gives every object an unique name it
tells you what site it comes from it
tells you how large it is tells you what
time period it lived in tells you its
latitude and longitude and you get that
for every single slice every single
depth stack but that's not what most
people are gonna want when they do their
research they're gonna want to the
derivative data
what's the 2d shape data or what's the
3d wireframe data so the pipeline also
includes automatic measures for
measuring shape and we're working on the
3d aspects of it at this moment so I'm
just gonna end by talking about the
challenges that we faced and the
challenges that we're still facing
actually and one of the big challenges
we're facing is that there is no open
access data storage infrastructure
within the United States as a whole for
this type of data there are multiple
different resource centers that claim to
be something like GenBank where you can
put morphological data but they're
actually not set up for data of this
magnitude so although I have a 50
terabytes server we've nearly filled it
up at this point so and a lot of the
data storage that we have the the way
that we cost out data storage internally
requires paying for data on a
year-by-year date basis which makes a
lot of sense given the importance of
data curation but it's very difficult to
write into a grant to say that you'd
like to pay for 50 terabytes of data for
a hundred years so the problem with
storing data forever is a big one but
I'd argue that it's an important one
because one of the brilliant things
about the whole genomics revolution was
not just what was done with the first
set of genetic data but it was the
reprocessing that was done afterwards
there was this whole ecosystem of
bioinformaticians
who then learned how to deal with the
data as time went on and you really have
to have a big pool of data for people to
work on in order to build up that sort
of community so I'm really quite
emphatic if that we need to keep this
data long enough to build up the
community to deal with it and that's a
really big problem
so recurred recurring data costs are
really prohibitive and it'd be fun to
think about alternative data pricing
structures that would allow
permanent data storage that can be
costed into a grant in an upfront math
manner the second takeaway is that yes
this data is messy it's not as perfect
as if you orient a fossil or take a
resolved 3d image but data volume itself
can be transformative and this is
something that we've really learned from
things like astronomy and genomics and
this message just keeps coming up over
and over again but data is just data
without people and really transforming
data into science and answering the
biggest most important questions
requires having the support of a broad
range of creative interactive people and
I've been really lucky to have that here
at Yale but I'd like to sort of beat the
drum that we have to keep this going if
we want to keep leading and data-driven
science so big data and measuring the
shape of life we're working on it guys
but we have a lot of outstanding
problems that could really benefit from
the expertise that's been built up over
the decades of working on astronomical
problems and genetic problems and all
the other network problems that you're
dealing on so there's the opportunity to
actually look at the processes that
underlie evolution itself which I find
terrifically exciting but there are
really big hurdles to doing this and no
single lab or no single university can
do it on their own so I'll just end with
this isn't just for tiny fossils these
approaches should be taken everywhere
but hopefully by starting it with tiny
fossils it provides a roadmap for others
who want to do something similar so
thank you
okay good afternoon I want to first
thank the organizers of the day of data
for inviting me to present some present
some of my research and I also want to
thank all of you for being here it's a
gorgeous Friday afternoon and you're all
inside hearing us talk about data so
very fortunate to have you all here and
looking forward to sharing some ideas
for those of you who are not familiar
with our research center the Yale Center
for Environmental Law and policy were a
joint think-tank between the School of
Forestry and environmental studies and
also Yale Law School we are founded in
1994 it's our 20th anniversary we are
not having a party unfortunately but it
just occurred to me today that we have
been around for 20 years and we seek to
apply academic rigor to real world
policymaking so I want to talk about one
of the projects that is our flagship
which is the environmental performance
index and so this project seeks to help
policymakers in the real world seek a
signal through very very noisy data and
so if there's one message that I want to
leave you with today is that measurement
matters and it matters for the
environment and so maybe you're familiar
with this old adage that you can't
manage what you don't measure and you
can't manage well what you don't measure
well well what I'm gonna argue and in my
research we actually see many gaps
currently in our understanding of many
environmental issues and so measurement
is still very salient and we still need
to do more of it for the environment so
arguably data and information and has
had salience for the environmental
domain since Rachel Carson in the 1960s
released her seminal work Silent Spring
and so in this work she used science and
demonstrated that pesticides were
accumulating in agriculture and food
change and endangering human health and
natural ecosystems and so by
demonstrating their toxicity she was
able to motivate a public awareness
campaign in order to raise awareness of
this of this important issue and the
danger of pesticides but if we look at
environmental policy throughout the
years since Rachel Carson released her
work and arguably started this
environmental movement in the United
States environmental policy has long
been plagued by information asymmetries
data gaps and so as a result a lot of
our policies have been based on educated
guesses but not
hard facts so I wish I had the problem
that Professor Gerstein presented which
is this hairball problem of having too
much data and not being able to distill
it down but actually in my work it's the
opposite we don't have enough data and
we actually have a lot of gaps so with
the rise of the Information Age we're
starting to slowly see a shift from
top-down command and control types of
governance and regulation to those that
increasingly emphasize the role that
data and information can play so the
command and control is that first bubble
top-down regulation moving more towards
economic market-based measures so right
now President Saliva's talking about an
internal carbon cap for the university
so that's falling into that second wave
but now we're really in this third wave
where there's a greater recognition that
information transparency and disclosure
can play a role in helping to drive
improvements in Environmental Policy and
so now we're embarking upon this phase
of Big Data as my colleagues just
mentioned where data is play more of an
active role where we can it can actually
drive improvements in Environmental
Policy and data and information can
whole scale restructure processes actors
and institutions so this is where our
work falls in particularly on the the
work that I'll discuss next which is on
indicators so what what are indicators
well indicators are taking some sort of
raw data and quantifying variables
through some type of transformation
statistically or some type of
normalization to then in the
environmental domain communicate some
sort of phenomenon environmental
pressure or state and so my work looks
at the role of indicators as they play
in this causal chain of moving from data
to information to eventually influencing
actors and policymakers and creating
some form of knowledge so the the lens
that my work squarely falls within is
the role of indicators in the policy
process so what might some of those
roles actually be well first of all we
see that indicators and policy can play
an instrumental role so they can be used
as tools to evaluate whether or not
programs are performing well or whether
or not there are some critical areas of
concern they can also play a conceptual
role so where there's a new idea or
trying to connect to disparate concepts
together indicators can actually bridge
ideas together so I have this picture of
a molecule because it's interesting when
I talk about indicators and data
policymakers they say to me I don't want
to learn chemistry I just want you to
tell me am i doing better am i doing
worse
so no chemistry no molecules no science
decision makers at least in my work they
don't want to hear it so they just want
to know up or down am I getting better
or worse and indicators can help provide
that information and last indicators can
also play a political role so I have a
picture of Francis Bacon here saying
knowledge is power and so in many cases
we see that policymakers use indicators
for some political purpose whether to
discredit a particular actor or to boost
their particular position so probably an
election cycle you hear a lot of this
statistics my opponent cause the economy
to downturn 10% etc so that's another
way that indicators are used in policy
so now I want to turn to the project
that I lead here at Yale more
specifically which is the environmental
performance index or epi I think we
might have some public health people
here so I don't want to confuse it with
epi and epidemiology because that's
something that gets very confusing on
Twitter when I just say epi so I wanted
to make that clear talking about
environment and what this is is this
global ranking that we produce by
annually here at Yale in conjunction
with Columbia University and we rank
countries on how well they perform on
high-priority environmental issues like
climate change air quality forests
fisheries etc so now I'll talk about how
we actually use data to create this
index and ranking while the EPI measures
performance and to policy objectives so
we look at impacts on human health so
that's on the right with the warm colors
and we also gauge performance in
ecosystems so that's the blue circle
right there so looking at these two
objectives were able to gauge how well
countries are performing and protecting
human health from environmental harm and
also preventing natural resource
degradation and then within these two
policy objectives we look at nine issue
areas so this is what I just mentioned
fisheries forests water and sanitation
etc and where the data actually comes in
is on the indicator scale so we look at
20 indicators for every single
and these indicators we use what we call
a proximity to target methodology so we
take raw data and then we determine a
top performance benchmark by which to
gauge how close or far every country is
to achieving that target so a question I
get very commonly is well how do you
determine what those targets are is in
that rather arbitrary well we try to be
objective by looking towards
international frameworks treaties
scientific thresholds something that's
objective that we can objectively gauge
every country's performance on where do
we get our data we have to look towards
official statistics so data that
countries report to UN agencies for
example or we rely on satellite data in
some cases we actually custom compile
our own data sets by calling up country
statistical offices to get to get the
data so once we're able to collect all
of that data and for every single
country calculate proximity to target
indicators we assign a series of
statistical weightings at each level
each level the circle to develop that
one number that represents a country's
environmental performance index score so
the size of the wedge in this wheel
roughly represents the statistical
weighting that we apply to each level of
aggregation so for the 2014 index which
was just launched this past January at
the World Economic Forum we ranked 178
countries around the world so to give
you a sense of how global that is that
constitutes around 99 percent of the
global population around 98 percent of
global land area and 97 percent of
global GDP so it's as much of a global
picture of the environment as you can
get that's really out there so just
taking a look at this map the higher
performing countries are in blue so
probably not surprisingly North America
European countries perform quite well
and the countries and orange performed
poorly so a lot of sub-saharan Africa we
have South Asia that performs quite
poorly and a lot of Central Asia as well
okay so what are some of the key
takeaways from this year's index and
this global picture of environmental
data and results well what we find is
that performance isn't consistent across
country across countries or across
issues so
if you look at results over the past
decade issues such as access to drinking
water reductions in child mortality
terrestrial habitat protection have been
improving over time and also are doing
quite well so the the y-axis is 0 to 100
so think of a report card with 100 being
an a-plus and zero being failing
miserably failing so actually fish
stocks miserably failing which is one of
the one of these dark green lines so
there are other issues such as
protecting fish species and protecting
populations against poor air quality
which are doing very very poorly so this
is something that we're able to do after
we compile all the data and analyze for
these global mega trends another
conclusion that we walked away with is
when you have measurement and management
align real progress can be achieved so
we call this slide here the tale of two
indicators falling off of Dickens the
yellow line represents the proportion of
the global population lacking access to
clean water whereas the orange line
represents the population globally
that's being exposed to poor air so very
very divergent trends and that reflects
the fact that through this international
framework called the Millennium
Development Goals there was a goal
identified to have the global population
lacking access to clean drinking water
by 2015 and in 2011 the world already
surpassed that goal so that's a prime
example of when you have international
systems that prioritize and put a lot of
investment into monitoring and managing
water you can she achieve real results
and then another way to look at that is
when the two are not aligned as in the
case of fisheries natural systems really
suffer so this is a plot over the last
sixty years of the percentage of fish
stocks that are either over exploited or
collapsed and very very surprising and
start trends here and it's largely
because a lot of governments don't
regularly measure and report on a lot of
these fish species so we had to actually
work with an independent organization
outside of the UN FAO to reconstruct the
time series of these fish data so that
we could get a sense of globally how
fish stocks are doing and it's not a
good picture it's not very optimistic
and last data gaps remain so I talked
about the fact that we don't yet as I
argue have big data for many of the
environmental issues that we would like
to gauge for the EPI so this is a map of
where cities report air quality data to
the
world health organization and you can
see many many gaps through most of
Africa Russia for example only has one
data point a lot of Southeast Asian
missing a lot of data and same with with
Latin America and in fact we're still
missing globally comparable data for
many of these issues that we would like
to engage countries performance on but
because there isn't any data we can't
include it in our API so that includes
things like desertification soil quality
wetlands lost nuclear safety so we don't
claim that the EPI is by any means
comprehensive but it really reflects as
much as the data that we have available
but also the many gaps that we still
face ok so another question I often get
asked is well how do you know that
anybody cares about the EPI and is this
actually making the policy impact that
you talked about earlier so I have
several theories as to how the EPI is
actually affecting and influencing
policy first of all by developing this
ranking by ranking countries from number
one to 178 what we're seeing happen is a
race to the top so countries are
competing against each other they're
saying well I'm Norway and Sweden is
doing so much better than me what is it
that they're doing that I can also do so
a great example is South Korea in 2002
in our first iterate one of our first
iterations of our index
they performed 136 out of 142 countries
and this was a huge slap in the face of
South Korea they said how could this be
there's no way we can be doing this
poorly and so they created the 136
environmental forum based on their ESI
score and they invited celebrities
policymakers city mayors civil society
representatives to come together to talk
about what they could do to improve
their score on this index another way we
see the EPI influencing policy is the
epi is becoming a platform for change
within countries so by presenting those
indicators consistently to every single
country they can make comparisons to
relevant peers and understand where they
might be leading and where they may
might be lagging so a prime example of
this is this this year we broke a story
in the New York Times that questioned
why the international attention has paid
a lot of focus to Beijing's poor air
quality but New Delhi which has
similarly bad air quality has been
ignored
so using satellite derived data this is
one of the very few cases in which we
actually do have some big data for the
environment we were able to show through
our indicators that India's air quality
is just as bad as China is if not worse
on some of our indicators and this is a
huge surprise to New Delhi's government
I came to work one day and every single
media organization had contacted me The
Economist New York Times Wall Street
Journal BBC and it was because of this
New York Times story that I mean it's a
terrible headline we don't want anybody
to be breathing any smoggy or bad air
but it really was motivating for the
Indian government I mean they were just
completely aghast and I said to them
well if you don't think your air quality
is as bad as Beijing's cough up the data
but the fact is is that you don't
regularly monitor any air quality in
your cities on a real-time basis and
some of our researchers went to their
official websites and found that they
were reporting reporting real-time data
as old as April of 2013 and this was
just this year in January so it was
quite shocking to them and since we
called them out in the New York Times
they have released or they have plans to
release a new air quality index that
will link together ambient measures of
air pollutants to health impacts because
people there also have no idea how bad
the air quality is so some of the Indian
policymakers that I spoken to have said
Oh air quality isn't a problem in India
it's not gonna be for another ten to
twenty years and what I've said to them
is no it's a problem now and because you
don't present any data it doesn't mean
it's not a problem and so I think that's
a I think a pretty powerful example for
how the EPI is actually playing into
these policy debates third we see that
the EPI is also working to set and
inform policy agendas so earlier this
year we actually had a delegation from
Iraq come and visit us this is at Yale
Law School and we had a delegation from
Iraq's Ministry of Environment and
Ministry of Planning come to us because
they were very very concerned about the
fact that in 2012 they performed last on
our API and they wanted to know how they
could do better so this was literally a
week before all the political situation
happened and Isis struck and so if they
had waited a week they would have been
able to come but this was quite
interesting for us because as academics
you operate sometimes in an ivy tower
you have no idea if anyone's paying
attention to what you're doing and this
is a case where they reached out to us
because they wanted to know how they
could do
and they were putting things on the
environmental policy agenda because they
were performing poorly in those areas on
the EPI last as I mentioned because we
look towards these international
frameworks the EPI can be a powerful
tool to help countries track progress
towards global goals so it's just in New
York earlier this week because the UN
General Assembly is meeting right now to
talk about the design of new global
sustainable development goals that will
take place in 2015 when these old
Millennium Development Goals expire and
so because we knew that this process was
coming this week in September when we
started to develop our data sets for the
EPI we were looking towards the proposed
sustainable development goals for
guidance as to what might be most
helpful for countries so this is one of
these data sets that I mentioned that we
custom compiled on wastewater treatment
so one of these scg's that's being
proposed is on water and they want
countries to track their percentage of
wastewater that they treat but currently
there doesn't exist any other data set
out there except for the one that we put
together to tell countries how they're
doing on this critical driver of fresh
water quality so this was one of one of
my researchers full-time job for about
four months it's putting together this
data set so it's it was a big
breakthrough for us as well okay so now
is the the ulterior motive to my being
here today which is a call to action to
anybody who wants to help us in this
effort of trying to get big data for the
environment and so what I mean I have a
definition of big data up here but I
think my colleagues have have gone over
sufficiently what we mean by big data
but what I argue is that we still don't
have big data yet for the environment
and that's mainly because whales don't
tweet trees don't shop on Amazon and
even though you have private sector
companies like Amazon and eBay Target
for example who have realized the value
of big data it's not yet happening or
being applied or thought of very much to
the environmental realm so as a result I
showed you all of those data gaps and
we're in the process of right now trying
to think about how we can fill in some
of those gaps but we desperately need as
much help as we can get
so one consideration that we're thinking
is how we might engage citizens and with
the proliferation of smartphones low
cost sensors citizen
science how we might engage everyday
people into helping us source data from
the bottom up instead of relying on data
source from the top down from
governments because we know that in our
research governments have variable
motivations to not report data hello
India or manipulate data
hello China so because of that I think
that this really calls for a data
revolution for us to engage citizens
companies non-state actors into this
effort to help us really understand some
of the most critical issues that face
the world today which would includes air
quality and climate change and these
problems are not getting better they're
getting worse
so towards that and I just want to point
to a couple projects that my team is
working on one is we publish this air
pollution map from an eco hackathon so
I'm actually hoping that we'll be able
to host one of these here at Yale and
that many of you will be able to
participate but it's especially on data
visualization because we found that
something that's very powerful is to
actually put all the data in an easily
consumed format and let people react to
it so we hacked this map of air
pollution data using our satellite data
and that whu-oh data set that I showed
you earlier and publish the map in the
Atlantic and NASA retweeted it shared it
all over their social media so we had
tens of thousands of people reacting and
commenting all over the world on air
quality in their country in their cities
and saying well why is my city this way
or why is my country doing that way and
why if I'm Russia is my government only
monitoring air pollution in Moscow so
that this is something that we found has
been very powerful in starting
conversations getting people excited
about data and another example that
we're going to be ready to launch is we
have a couple students who are computer
science majors and programmers who've
been working with us to translate are
very dense scientific findings on data
and indicators into a more easily
digestible fun and attractive way so
they've taken this special issue on the
next-generation air quality indicators
that we published in atmospheric
environment and developing a series of
interactive infographics so that people
can learn about where the data gaps are
what needs to be done and hopefully we
can motivate political action that way
so I encourage everyone to visit our
website it's epi yale.edu I also have a
couple colleagues in the back Andrew
presented a poster on the EPI earlier so
if you didn't get a chance to see that
definitely find him afterwards cuz he
did a very cool interactive display with
multiple iPads so it was quite fun but
yes please get in touch and we'd love to
hear from you and hear any feedback that
you might have about our project so
thanks so much thanks to all the
speakers we have a few minutes for
questions if you want to raise your hand
and we'll make sure your you're close to
a microphone
this is for the environmental talk it
strikes me that in the presentation that
you not only tried to master the data
that you had available you tried to
harness the power of the internet to
lobby for more data and also to help
people understand the data that you had
and I think that last piece of helping
people who are not necessarily expert in
the domain in which you're working
understand the data and make it every
man's data every person's data I think
is a laudable goal and I'd be curious
for you to comment a little bit about
the process that you will gone through
or your group has gone through to try to
get a handle on that hello okay that's a
great question and so I've been at Yale
this is my seventh year now and I've
been running this project for four and
it definitely took a lot of convincing
of my colleagues and my PhD advisor that
this is actually something that is
really worthwhile and this I do policy
research so what good is it if I just
publish a bunch of dense scientific
articles which I have to do for my
tenure process but at the same time
students who are in our master's program
are only around for two years and so
they and many of them are professional
degree students so they're not here to
do research degrees and so I thought
about well how can we best utilize our
students interests and time and skills
in a way that will also help them get
jobs I mean they want to go and work for
think tanks and want to do policy
research consulting nobody wants to read
an academic paper that they've written
for a class they want to know that they
know how to do Sharpe policy analysis
that they know how to use and interpret
data sharply and so from that I said I
think we need to raise a lot of money to
invest in a better website because our
website before no offense to any
statistician out there but it was a
statistician who did our website and it
was it was good for a statistician but
it was very difficult to interpret a lot
of the scatter plots that were included
on the website so it's it definitely it
takes a little bit of it took it took me
a little bit of galvanizing my
colleagues but I think once they realize
what vision I had and the results and
the the response that we got I think now
it's pretty much selling itself so we've
had a lot of other research centers
within our school approached us and say
who did your web design what
students do you work with is we pull
from students from the art program from
the School of Architecture from our own
school because it has to be
interdisciplinary and it's fun for the
students because then they get to learn
skills from the computer programmers
from the statisticians from the policy
research folks and so it's been it's
been a it's been a process it has not
been very easy but I think that now
we're starting to hit our stride and get
a lot of recognition for what we're
doing but it is very very challenging
because I can't edit blog post every day
and manage programming projects and so
I've actually now I've hired somebody
who can help coordinate all of the
outreach and then I can focus more on
the research but it certainly is
challenging but I think it's really
really worthwhile and I'm happy to share
my experience if anybody wants to have a
meeting because I think it's so
worthwhile I think there's so much great
research that goes on here at Yale but
it gets lost within the the ivory tower
angel so you pointed out you know there
were obvious and for obvious reasons big
gaps in the part of the data so it's
it's common practice in like in geology
looking at paleo climate and so forth to
use various proxies yes do you have
other ways to do that here or we have
lots of proxies but they're not very
good so our agricultural category for
example we have very very crude policy
proxies so we say well have countries
banned or restricted their pesticide use
according to the Stockholm Convention
which regulates these pesticides but it
doesn't actually say anything about on
the ground whether or not they've
actually implemented those commitments
so we have to use a lot of proxies even
this wastewater treatment indicator is a
crude proxy for fresh water quality so
we would like to be able to have
comparable water quality for all
freshwater bodies in countries around
the world but for a multitude of reasons
that just isn't possible we just don't
have any global indicator of water
quality and so yeah we definitely rely a
lot on proxies but governments don't
really like that they want to know the
output measures and and what is the
condition on the ground and that's why I
don't think we're there yet and I don't
think we yet have big data to do that
but that's a really good point I come
questions
is it possible to use like a phone app
to measure air quality yet it's s first
question second question is how do you
deal with known under estimates from
various people when you don't when you
have to rely on government stuff and the
third really nerdy question is how did
you choose the weights for your various
categories so for the first question yes
people are designing phone sensors so
there's a Swedish company that has
developed some iPhone I guess like
attachments that you can connect to your
phone that will measure things like
carbon monoxide and particulate matter
and various things there about $99 right
now so that's still not I think as cheap
as it needs to be but I taught a class
at Yale College last spring that was
looking at urbanization and environment
in China and India and my students just
downloaded some instructions off the
internet and built a cheap sensor for
about 25 bucks so I think it can be done
but a huge question is what is the
reliability of that data how quality is
it and so that's something that we're
working on right now to try to I mean
it'd be great to also include this as
part of our hackathon get the computer
scientist and the engineering students
and researchers together so that we can
manufacture very cheap sensors ship them
all over the world and collect better
data and to your other question about
the waiting's that is a very hotly
debated topic amongst our team and also
with external audiences and so we have
to we try to look at the quality of the
data and whether or not it's a proxy if
it's an actual measure or if it's a
proxy so we down wait the proxies we
don't wait them as much as we do the
actual output on the ground measures and
then we debate them we say oh is is the
data quality good is there any reason
why we should be downloading those so
it's very very subjective and a lot of
countries complain to us and say I don't
agree with your weighting of this this
issue or that issue so I forgot your
second question but hopefully I answered
it
oh yes bias that's that's a problem
that's a huge problem what we would like
to do is to eventually publish
uncertainty estimates and confidence
intervals for every single one of our
indicators but with the government
reported statistics you can't do that
because a lot of times when they report
data to the UN they don't report the
uncertainty estimates so it's very very
crude and this is one of the reasons why
I think we need to get big data because
then when n equals all right then you
don't have those problems so or you you
shouldn't have those problems in theory
but yeah mark when you see these federal
mandates for data sharing policies you
know mcc's data sharing policies as as a
researcher do you look at this and say
wow this is great
or what do I need to do just to get this
through the door and not have to spend
so much time on it I certainly think
that the emphasis on data sharing is a
good thing obviously all all day and
analysts love when people produce more
data and they share it I mean that's
sort of general truth though I do think
that it is the case that increasingly
with data sharing there it is somewhat
cumbersome sometimes and a lot of times
you know I you know collaborate and
interact a lot of with a lot of
researchers who are working towards
those policies and I realize how much
work it is and how very complicated it
is and sometimes you do get the sense
that a lot of people think that it's
more work to share it then it's actually
generated or and so forth and I do think
there are times when the data sharing it
maybe is not in the best interest you
know if it's better just to get the
answer and you know generate another
data set and so forth and to go through
all the work of trying to share it and
so forth there's no more questions were
scheduled for a short 10-minute break
and we'll reconvene for the next session
at at roughly 255 join me in thanking
the presenters again